it's nice and fan yeah liver tones maybe
trout stays like water
so how do you feel about water I love it
I drink water I drink it all day
I like Dasani it tastes like minerals
I've drank water in all its forms tap
water toilet water sink water pour water
I'll drink it what flavors do you like
it more
I like plain I feel like when it comes
to water I just kind of take what I
could get yeah and it's like an
affordable honestly I'm doing more
surprised I can afford to live so we
have three different brands the cheapest
being Sahni the middle point fiji water
and the highest price well you're a
Dasani fan so this should be pretty easy
for you let's see how much we are this
one's got a lot of moles it smells in
water okay
he's like water the bubble they thought
be chaos number you sure oh she's flat
but she's four she's traveled when she
went to her 20s last one
trace I almost tried to snip it
that's Dasani I don't realize I don't
quite know what the sonic tastes like
despite my love of it that's some nasty
Dasani for sure you know they all kind
of taste the same there's like an
aftertaste to this one Dede from the
blob scene your neighborhood girl you
probably dated her in high school broke
up with her she's so like poetry about
you at the local poetry slam and that
does asani i'm gonna walk out of here
violet please I actually feel like this
one might be Dasani now they all taste
bad because of the Dasani I also
recognize I'm gonna look like a complete
fool if this isn't Bassani but like I'm
putting all my eggs in this basket the
boss would come from a glass bottle
which I feel like doesn't give it
anything I think that's why it would be
the flattest I thought I knew water but
I don't this one tastes the most crisp
and I'd like to think that expensive
water is good water because it's like
harvested from the mountains of I don't
know Machu Picchu whatever is like a
nice mountain
peih-gee boss decide fiji Dasani boss
boss Dasani boss fiji beside you guys so
embarrassing
this is so why does loss it's like that
I don't know I feel like it should taste
the most like nothing it has like a
cardboard taste to it like essence of
box dee dee you and the girl I left the
high school baby
but I'm coming back features nice too
though I'll give it that I mean I
checked it so I don't remember what it
tastes like mostly like water so both of
these are like that I think they're all
great I think all water brands are great
you just too damn over a price I'm angry
that I got that so wrong I'd still pick
this on me like I'd buy the cheapest one
I'm not gonna shell out for expensive
water I drink tap water it's fine I
still think Dasani hands down is the
best tasting bottled water that there is
honestly all water tastes the same
oh it's like water unless it's really
expensive then it's got some weird
aftertaste to it I was really confused
by that shoot you're gonna be foreign
but we all knew that lace-front was
showing
[Laughter]
you